[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEN PERSON: Welcome
to "Getting Started
with Artifact Registry."
Today, I'll show you how to
deploy a container stored
in an Artifact
Registry repository
to Google Kubernetes Engine.
If you're new the
Artifact Registry,
I recommend you check
out the last episode
of "Getting Started"
or the documentation
before proceeding.
With that in mind, let's walk
through deploying to GKE.
Now there's a good chance that
if you're watching this video,
you already know about
Google Kubernetes Engine,
but to get everyone up to speed,
let's have a quick overview.
GKE is an enterprise
grade platform
for containerized
applications, including
stateful and stateless, AI
and ML, Linux and Windows,
complex and simple web apps,
API and backend services.
You can use GKE to leverage
industry-first features,
like four-way auto scaling
and no-stress management.
You can also optimize
GPU and TPU provisioning,
use integrated developer tools,
and get multi cluster support
from SREs.
So why use Artifact
Registry then with GKE?
Using Artifact Registry
with GKE gives you
the ability to manage all of
your artifacts in one place.
So for example, you can
build Maven packages,
push them to Artifact
Registry, containerize them
with Cloud Build in Jib,
and then deploy them to GKE,
all while using
consistent IM across the
build process, artifact
management, and GKE.
Artifact Registry also
enables you to run
in fully regionalized stacks.
So with Artifact Registry,
an Australian or South
American customer
can run GKE clusters
and manage container
images in the same region,
and pay no egress costs
while they pull images.
Pretty sweet, huh?
So without further ado,
let's deploy to GKE.
First, start with
new or existing code.
Here's a simple
Go helloworld app
that I'm going to
use in my container.
You can also take a
look at my Dockerfile
here for kicks, though it's
pretty much boilerplate.
See below for a link
to the documentation
where you can see
this file in detail.
I'm using Cloud Build to build
this project, but keep in mind
that you don't have to.
Using Cloud Build allows
you to automatically push
the image to Artifact Registry,
which I like because it
streamlines the deploy process.
These next couple steps are
for building with Cloud Build
if you don't already know
your cloud project ID,
you can get it by
running this command.
Now create a file
called cloudbuild.yaml.
Here's the contents
of that file,
but don't worry about rushing
to pause the video so you
can copy this down.
You can find this code in
the documentation, which
of course is linked below.
These variables,
repository and image,
are used for the repository
name and the name
of the image in
the repository so
that they can be replaced
at built time using custom
Cloud Build substitutions.
This is very useful if you want
to use the same build config
file to push images
to repositories
for different environments,
such as testing, staging, and/or
production.
For example, this
command would substitute
draynepipe for the
repository name,
and my image for the image name.
I run this command to
submit my container
to build using Cloud Build.
It is then stored
using Artifact Registry
in the draynepipe repository.
Now that you have a project
built and ready to go,
you may need to configure
access to your container.
Check the docs to see
the minimum required GKE
versions to create
clusters that have
default permissions
to pull containers
from Docker repositories
in the same project.
If you are not using one
of these GKE versions,
you will need to
configure access
to pull containers using
Kubernetes imagePullSecrets.
If you need to access
containers from repositories
in another project,
then you need
to grant read permission on
that repository to the identity
being used to pull the image.
Once that access
is configured, you
can run an Artifact Registry
image on a GKE cluster
using this command.
Where "name" is the name
you've given the object,
"location" is the regional
or multi-regional location
of your repository,
"project ID" is, of course,
your Google Cloud project ID.
"Repository" is the
name of the repository
where the image is stored.
"Image" is the name of the
image in the repository,
and "tag" is the tag
for the image version
that you want to pull.
So for my draynepipe project,
I'd use this command.
And now my image that's
stored in an Artifact Registry
repository is deployed to GKE.
Want to see more on deploying
to Google Kubernetes
Engine with Artifact Registry?
Check out the Artifact
Registry quickstart for Docker,
and the Artifact Registry
guide on integrating
with Google Kubernetes Engine.
Do you have any questions
about Artifact Registry?
Feel free to comment
below or tweet at me.
Thanks for watching,
and I'll see you
on the next "Getting Started
with Artifact Registry."
[MUSIC PLAYING]